you were gonna make another movie this  year yeah  what is confer fans what is that movie  and where and when are you she was  called cherry it's based on a book it's  about a soldier who comes back from the  Iraq war a decorated soldier PTSD and he  slides into addiction to try to control  those PTSD it's um it's a treatise on  the opioid epidemic starting Tom Holland  it's a very different role for Tom and I  will be shooting it in Cleveland this  summer what was it about that material  that said because I would imagine that  after these movies and what you your  track record you could do anything so  what was it about this material that  said this is it well the subject matter  is profound and and you know the  epidemic is staggering and I think that  we you know we've had people close to us  in our lives that we lost due to the  epidemic and it just felt like a an area  that we were exceedingly passionate  about telling story